[تصفيق]
هل تدخل حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا منعطفا
اكثر خطوره ستحمل هذه الدبابات قذائفه لها
تاثيرات اكثر من اختراق الدروع هذه
الدبابات من طراز ابرز الامريكيه وصلت
دفعات منها للقوات الاوكرانيه خلال الشهور
القليله الماضيه ووعدت واشنطن بالمزيد في
الوقت نفسه اكد الجيش البريطاني تسليم
القوات الاوكرانيه قذائف محمله باليوراني
من منظب في مارس الماضي تلك ماده تنتج في
المفاعلات النوويه نتيجه تخصيب اليورانيوم
ولليورانيم المنظم استخدامات سلميه كثيره
لكن استخداماته العسكريه اكثر فعاليه
وخطوره قد يستخدم اليورانيوم المنظم في
تغطيه الفولاذ المكون لارسام الدبابات
والطائرات والدروع ليعطيها حمايه اكثر لكن
الجدل يكمن في استخدام اليورانيوم المنظم
في القذائف عندما ينفجر يمكنه اختراق
الدبابات والدروع بسهوله اكبر اذ تصطدم
قذيفه اليورانيم المنظم بالهدف لتحترق
ذاتيا في درجه حراره عاليه تنبعث معها
جزيئات اليورانيوم متناهيه في الغلاف
الجوي التاثير الضار يتم عند استنشاق هذه
الجزيئات في رئتي الانسان او ذوبانها في
التربه حذر اطباء الجيش البريطاني من ان
التعرض لليورانيوم المنظم يزيد من خطر
الاصابه بسرطان الرئه واللمفاويه والدماغ
على المدى الطويل تكون الخطوره في تسريب
اليورانيوم المنظم الى مياه الشرب
والسلسله الغذائيه من خلال الهجره من
التربه او الترسيب المباشر على الغطاء
النباتي في المقابل يقول معهد الامم
المتحده لبحوث نزع السلاح انه لا يمكن
اعتباره ذخيره اليورانيوم والمنظم اسلحه
النوويه لانه لا يفي بالتعريف القانونيه
للاسلحه النوويه او الاشعاعيه او السامه
او الكيميائيه لكن تقريرا منذ عام 2010
للجنه العلميه الاوروبيه خلص الى ان هناك
خطرا صحيا محدودا لانفجار اليورانيوم
المنظم موصيه بابعاد مناطق القتال ومعالجه
الجثث المتضرره من هذه الذخائر وجعل
الوصول اليها مستحيل
لكن المناطق التي استخدم فيها اليورانيوم
المنظم لا تزال تعاني الشواهد حيه في
العراق الذي كان مسرحا لهذه القذائف
الامريكيه في حرب الخليج عام 91 وغزو
البلاد عام 2003 كذلك الامر في صربيا اذ
استخدمه في الحرب هناك عام 99 رفضا لتهوين
الغربي من خطوره هذه القذائف التي قد
تستخدمها كييف تهدد موسكو بان المنطقه
ستدخل منعطفا اخر اكثر خطوره خلال هذه
الحرب وعلى الاجيال القادمه